capitale de la bourgogne
carrefour européen ses nombreux
monuments sont les jalons d'une histoire
riche et mouvementée
situé à proximité du vignoble et sur la
route des épices
dijon est le berceau de la moutarde
alors parlez moi à coups de lame hauteur
de dijon la moutarde de dijon c'est à
dire que la moutarde elle même
elle est très dense et très ancien ça
date de quand l'antiquité l'antiquité
oui et des gens l'ont trouvé ici a déjà
oui mais on en a trouvé surtout à partir
de philippe lebon qui a qui aimait
beaucoup la moutarde et c'est lui un peu
qu'il l'a mis en valeur
c'était un jukebox et un duc de
bourgogne s'est elle avait comme femme
isabelle de portugal qui est mais c'est
elle qui a mis du reste le menu une
exécution et à ce moment là la presle
escrito elle mettait beaucoup de
moutarde dans la cuisine qu'elle faisait
parce que c'est elle savait très bien
faire la cuisine
et puis c'est lui qui disait de trois
choses dieu me garde d'un valet qui se
regardent d'abord bouillie son moutarde
et d'une femme qui se farde
dans la maison du musicien jean philippe
rameau siège la commanderie des cordons
bleus
créée par gaston gérard elle nous reçoit
aujourd'hui pour la confection du poulet
gaston gérard
alors il faut naturellement à poulets de
la moutarde du sel du poivre
du paprika
du beurre du vin de bourgogne à valence
est de la crème et du soin match de
compter
et
vous allez nous exécuter leur fait
maintenant c'est jacqueline la fage mon
amie avec laquelle je fais souvent ce
poulet qui va commencer exécuté très
bien vous le coupez d'abord
alors je vais faire revenir un peu le
poulet avec un peu d'huile et de beurre
vous mettez beaucoup de bord que oui
c'est que meilleure semaine et je mets
de l'huile pour empêcher le beurre de
brûler et je t'ai revenir tous les
morceaux
voilà on fait revenir les morceaux
tantôt légèrement mais pas trop de roue
on voudrait des procès dans les mets de
côté pour faire de la place dans la
cocotte pour les noms suivants alors
j'ai beau me tous les morceaux dans la
cocotte
maintenant qu'ils sont tous bien revenue
je vais mettre du sel
évidemment je procède à samuel du poids
de moulins bien sûr
et du paprika
ils ont été beaucoup trop tard twin
rahmane d'ailleurs ça donne une jolie
coloration but et ils sont tous très
bien a plié de selectica je ferme la
cocotte et je laisse cuire une bonne
demi-heure à feu comment à feu doux
alors que pour les faire revenir vous
étiez à feu sévira fait assez vif pour
les faire revenir
mais après il faut que ça cuit doucement
pour faire du jus et si avec ce jus
rendu par la cuisson du poulet
c'est avec ce jus qu'on va faire la
sauce tout à l'heure tout à l'heure en
presque au moment de ne pas tout à fait
au moment de servir mais enfin a
maintenant un quart d'heure avant alors
pendant que ça cuit dans la cocotte je
vais faire du fromage rapplique du
gruyère râpé
en fin de compte et vous allez me dire
un petit peu quelle quantité vous alors
pour un kilo pour en peu près 1 kilos
800 de poulet jeu mais 200 g de comté
202 compter une cuillère à dessert de
moutarde deux verres de vin blanc et un
bon bol d'être m
mais j'aime toujours mon rap mon comté
au moment de le faire mais c'est pas une
recette qui revient très cher non non
moi je mets du très bon poulet alors
évidemment il ya tous les prix ça fait
quand même pas une
viendrez cher ça fait donc une demi
heure que le poulet cuit alors on va
voir s'il est à point oui alors je vais
sortir les morceaux dans le plat qui
servira pour le service cet emploi qui
doit aller au four qui doit aller au
four et qui est servi directement sur la
table ensuite
alors évidemment on ne met pas les
morceaux de carcasses que j'ai mis moi
la cuire pour faire le jus mais on n'y
met pas en doute là vous allez les
débarrasser à la la alors je mets le
plat au four par ce moyen
simplement pour tenir le poulet au chaud
pendant ce temps là je vais continuer de
faire la sauce verbe et des morceaux de
carcasses
[Applaudissements]
si je fais je vais faire la sauce jazz
et fergie la sauce avec le jus de
cuisson
je vais mettre le vin blanc alors deux
verres à moutarde de vin blanc pressecq
communal tout à l'heure du bourgogne de
procédures ou one de préférence
voilà et je vais ajouter petit à petit
mon comté et je remue sans arrêt pour
qu'ils font du bien alors maintenant que
le fromage et bien fondu je vais ajouter
la crème et la moutarde commencer par la
crème dont la valeur d'un bon bol et je
vais ajouter la moutarde
alors la valeur à peu près d'une
cuillère à soupe de toute façon je vais
goûter pour voir s'il a soudainement
d'un season mans et bien déjà à l'odeur
on a une idée oui nous bénéficions d'une
odeur très très agréable ça montera pas
l'air mal bon alors maintenant que la
sauce est terminée je vais reprendre le
plat du four
attention aux pneus brûlés voilà je
verse la sauce dans le plat
il ya beaucoup de choses il faut il faut
beaucoup de choses dans ce plat
voilà et puis on reprend un peu de rap
et quand saupoudre et on peut si on veut
terminer par un petit peu de chapelure
ça le fait un petit peu plus gratiné un
petit peu plus dorée à l'achat pur c'est
pas obligatoire non non non sport ça
fait plus croustillant ça fait une
petite croûte
en fait ce n'est pas obligatoire et
alors maintenant on le met à brac signer
sous la grille du four
d'accord vous leur mettez dans
malheureux mais alors là maintenant sous
le sous le gril war on surveille pour
qu'ils soient bien dorés juste à point
il est très bien réussi leurs jambes à
leurs fins en bonne voie
[Musique]
d'el islah